welcome to the heavy spoilers show
my name's paul and i'm pleased to eat
you
now army of the dead is now out and the
movie has a lot of questions hanging
over it
the film is packed with weird little
details that hint towards ufos
robot zombies time loops and even the
possibility that van der rohe is
actually zeus
over the weekend i dedicated myself to
unearthing the answers
and after compiling interviews with zack
snyder i've come up with some theories
and answers to the questions that have
no doubt been picking your brains
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out yet then i
recommend that you check out now
drop the thumbs up as that's a
no-brainer and make sure you subscribe
to the channel as this is where we
explain
everything from a to world war z
terrible now
without the way thank you for clicking
this thank you for sticking with me
now let's get into the breakdown of army
of the dead
okay so the movie opens with the
military transporting the alpha zombie
zeus across the desert
this convoy picks the character up from
area 51
which is of course synonymous with
aliens for decades people have theorized
that the secret military base in the
nevada desert was set up after an
alien spaceship crash landed there and
since the 50s
there's been a lot of mystery
surrounding the location
extraterrestrials have two been linked
with zombies for a long time
and recently it was revealed by robert
kirkman that the outbreak in the walking
dead
was caused by a space spore that fell to
earth night of the living dead two had
theories in it that said the zombie
outbreak may have been caused by nasa
shooting down a satellite on its way to
venus
due to the radiation that it was
carrying it returned to earth
and brought the dead back to life this
radiation could be what kills people
upon being bit
and from there it may reanimate their
corpse much like the two soldiers we
meet in the opening
fans have been theorizing over exactly
what's going on with the virus
and because of the location we can guess
that it was caused by experiments
carried out at area 51.
you can also see two bright white lights
in the sky hovering over the base
and these shoot off as the transport
makes its way out of the area
51 now personally i think that the
undead are actually created through
hybrid human and alien dna
and there is some evidence for this in
the movie when zeus is shot at the end
of the film
within the red blood that squirts from
his head we can also catch flashes of
blue
when the fetus is pulled from zeus's
ghoul friend if you look closely you can
see that its blood vessels beneath its
skin
are glowing blue as well whilst zeus and
the alphas do look like your typical
zombie
i actually think there's more going on
than meets the eye personally i think
that the characters aren't your typical
shamblers
and they're actually living creatures
that just appear to be like the undead
they are gods a new form of human that's
an alien hybrid who's able to reproduce
i believe that the government were
carrying out experiments at area 51
in order to create a new kind of soldier
and after perfecting this they went to
transport zeus across the country to the
next stage
but the vehicle was destroyed and the
alpha was unleashed
martin was then sent in to retrieve the
head of the bride and
using this they'd still be able to carry
on their work
to cover up what happened the government
would then nuke the site
so that all the evidence was buried and
in my opinion if you're looking for what
caused the virus
then it was aliens now along with these
blue-blooded alphas
we can also catch a robot zombie mikey
guzman shoots one in the casino at one
point
and after electricity bursts from its
head we can also see a terminator-esque
skull underneath its skin
when they die they end up robotin which
is like rotten but
with robot never mind and snyder
recently teased about what was going on
with this in a q a session with netflix
he indeed confirmed that her eyes
weren't deceiving us and that this
is in fact a zombie robot when
discussing the point of these mechanical
monsters
the director stated i had the idea from
the beginning that these zombies were
going to embody an evolution
they were on their way to becoming
something else not stagnant like the
zombies were used to
it was a way to make them fresh while
still delivering on the zombie cannon in
some ways
i really wanted this sort of weird
ambiguity to their origins
which of course we'll explore in the
animated series
army of the dead lost vegas without
giving too much away
if you pay close attention there's a
number of zombies that are clearly not
zombies
you see normal zombies and then you see
some robot zombies
are they monitors that the government
has placed among the zombies to monitor
them
are they technology from the other world
what's happening there
so yeah this will be explored in the
upcoming anime
but judging by the last couple of
sentences by snyder
i do think it will be revealed that
their government plans put in to monitor
the situation
the new deadline being moved up is a
weird one and they could have been
monitoring things from the inside and
moved the missile launch time up after
spying on the group
like snyder says there's a number of
them in the film i think i also caught
one when zeus is carrying the bride in
you can notice to the left of the screen
that there are glowing blue eyes and a
shambler
which may be indicating that this one is
indeed a government plant
let me know if you spotted any others as
i'd love to see if there's more dotted
about the film
now as for the time loop this is sort of
being cleared up by snyder 2 and
in a recent live stream with film junkie
he discussed the bodies that the
characters come across in the vault
we can see that they're wearing the same
clothes as the group and it's theorized
by van der rohe that this is actually
one infinite loop
in which they are living out the same
events over and over and over
there are some subtle hints that there
are several versions that have already
attempted to take
the money and when the group arrive at
the table in the casino
we see some corpses slumped over it
scott ward asks if those are another set
of blueprints to the safe
and this is confirmed but then sort of
glossed over
so there are at least three versions of
the group that we see in the film
when talking to film junkie snyder said
i'll also say that
like there's a chance i'm not saying
this is 100 true
and in some ways it's not but the group
at the table i mean
it's pretty subtle but that's them also
at the table as well
they get farther every time like this is
the time that they made it all the way
to the money
so very strange things going on in the
movie and because of the way that the
film is set up
it's almost impossible to fully guess
exactly what's going on here however
it is possible that the nuke which
always ends the situation
carries a lot with it nukes atoms and
the study of them
also tends to lend itself to the
observation of tachyons which are
particles that actually have the ability
to move backwards through time
snyder played upon this notion in his
film watchmen and army of the dead could
be making a nod to that too
it is possible that every time the knee
goes off it resets the situation
and sends the group back to the start
where they make their way through vegas
carrying out slightly different choices
each time there are potentially
thousands of versions of this film that
we haven't seen
and the final one in which everything
goes the way it should is the one that
we witness
i even have a theory that aliens are
pulling the strings in order for the
virus to get further out
and the one situation in which they win
is when van der rohe gets to the vault
is safe from the nuke and is then able
to go on to become the omega to zeus's
alpha
now another question that i had and i
know some of you did
is how the hell did van der rohe survive
the nuclear fallout caused by the blast
even with the safe offering shelter as
soon as he stepped out into the
wasteland the radiation would have
killed him within minutes
however it is possible that because he
was infected that he was able to survive
this
as we've discussed in the video
radiation could have been crucial to
causing the undead to rise
and thus with the virus flowing through
his veins he may now be immune to the
devastation caused by the nuke
as for van der rohe i have seen a lot of
theories suggesting that he might
actually be zeus himself
and the end of the movie might loop
around into him ending up in the
container at the start of the film now
up top i think we should clarify this
and say that van der rohe and zeus are
played by two totally different actors
the theory states though that because
zeus has similar hair to van der rohe
when we first meet him
and he may actually be a version of the
character when the alpha arrives at
vegas
we also see that he's inspired by the
statue of zeus in front of the olympus
casino
now strangely at this point amari
hardwick's name pops on the screen
suggesting that he too could be playing
zeus the alpha and omega typically means
the beginning and
end and thus this could be one big loop
in which the alpha creates its omega
which goes on to create it there's this
idea of birth and resurrection and van
der rohe even hints to this when
discussing the hero's journey by
joseph campbell his almost cyclical way
of telling his story
involves a character traveling into the
abyss or what's referred to as the belly
of the beast
they have a revelation that takes them
on a path of transformation
and van der rohe realizing he's been
bitten could be that moment
and shout out to flix in the city for
suggesting that radiation hitting the
safe could have somehow changed and
mutated van der rohe
even more and perhaps helped to create a
new kind of zombie
we never actually see van der rohe get
bitten so there's a lot of things
potentially going on with him
jan also said it's possible that when
van der rohe emerges from the vault
but he's actually in another timeline
where things start all over again
it's quite a cool little fan theory and
i'd definitely love to hear what you
think and if there's any other questions
or thoughts that you have on the film
make sure you comment below and let me
know and as a thank you for interacting
with the video
you'll be entered into a prize during
the 30th of may in which we're giving
away three copies of the godzilla vs
kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the theories
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter
at heavyspoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of the film
including the news about the prequels
sequels and what we took from the ending
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace